[Music]
and no equals not yet is one of my kind
of favorite favorite mantras and a
mental hack that was very helpful to me
I think early in my career I like many
people worked for a classic gatekeeper
boss and he had all the answers and the
team got quite frustrated we thought we
had a different way different ideas to
keep us contemporary and move forward
and he said no I ended up leaving that
job because I thought the gatekeeper was
standing in my way and what I came to
realize is that gatekeepers exist
everywhere they're probably even in our
own heads sometimes where we just say we
can't do it and so out of that
experience I realized there were a lot
of ways I could have kept going back and
trying a different approach with the
gatekeeper and I learned that with other
gatekeepers and that no is not yet so
just because you hear no the first time
it doesn't mean no is final and I can't
tell you how many people I've seen in
the course of my career I'm talking
people just starting out which may be a
little bit more understandable because
you don't know yet all the way up to
CEOs when they hear know from whatever
person they're pitching an idea to they
leave and you never see him again with
that idea and you think well you had all
this passion you had all this insight
someone told you no and you just let it
dissipate it's gone so to me I had to
learn like no perhaps as an invitation
an invitation to come back again to try
it I had a three time rule that I would
often use with different bosses I had
where I felt like I needed at least
three times to go back with the idea
what I learned is two things one is I'm
testing the idea myself I'm trying to
like put the right words together
sometimes it's just the the words are
wrong the story's not there I'm not
being clear and I think if it's the
manager or you're someone's coming to
you you're testing their passion for it
you're testing how good an idea they
think it is because if somebody's
pitching you an idea but they're not
that excited about it you're counting on
them to go forward so I think this idea
of no is not yet is a resiliency test
it's a way to say how much do you care
about that idea how much do you want it
to happen
it's a it's a sign of commitment to the
idea right yeah disappointment is an
inevitable part of making change of
pushing for innovation and I think we
have this fantasy that we buy in that
you just pitch a brilliant idea
you're just so fantastic fantastically
suited for it you just go forth and the
idea gets greenlit and off you go the
reality is just because you're well
liked your boss likes you your team
likes you you've had a good track record
doesn't mean people are going to give
you blind trusts that the next idea is
good people want to know what are you
prepared to do to work for it and I've
found certainly in myself and in people
I've worked with that often it's those
those try again moments where you didn't
quite get off the right foot in pitching
the idea or maybe you did a test of it
and it didn't work and it's when you
come back and say I tried this and it
didn't work here I'm disappointed
here's what I propose to do about it so
I think a lot of this kind of resiliency
building is a test of how do you deal
with the disappointment and I think
disappointment is something you have to
accept as part of the change making
process I am I have a little belief in
my that for myself that there's a time
to be disappointed I'm really sad that
that idea didn't get bought in in a
sense that I couldn't sell it people
didn't like they didn't understand what
I was saying am I crazy
do I not communicate and I'm upset I'm
upset and so I think you have to give
yourself a little bit of time to kind of
suck your thumb and say I didn't I
didn't do as well as I wanted but then
go do I still believe in it is it still
a good idea how do I take that feedback
and now I'll go back and address some of
those issues if they're relevant and use
that disappointment as a bit again of
that kind of push a bit a kick it kick
in the butt to get out there so just
because you have a good track record
doesn't mean you're going to accept be
successful the next time and use that
disappointment to to be a bit of rocket
fuel for yourself learn from it but also
say hey do I do I still want to do this
so so that's how I think about
disappointment and kind of using it as
resiliency
[Music]